president Lavigne mr. secretary-general
ladies and gentlemen I cannot think of
most difficult time for the United
Nations secretary-general mr. Kofi Annan
to leave his New York headquarters to
attend misspeaking engagement even if
this engagement is at such a fine place
at Yale University than this time I do
not exaggerate when I say that the
multilateral system the international
system is going right now through one of
its most testing moments in post Cold
War times yet mr. secretary-general has
decided in spite of this very difficult
situation that the United Nations
Security Council is going through to
come with us this afternoon so I will
not use his time and you say that we are
extremely pleased I'm very grateful that
you mr. Kofi Annan is here this
afternoon thank you very much
thank you
thank you very much president said you
mr. president and what a wonderful
welcome I think if you keep her
welcoming me like this maybe nan and I
will move from New York and join you
here
distinguished faculty and dear students
it is a great pleasure for me to visit
Yale and to pay tribute to the very
important work that will be done by the
Center for globalization by devoting the
remarkable intellectual resources of
this institution to the central
phenomenon of our time you can help
guide us in understanding and grappling
with the sweeping changes affecting the
world let me also say how valuable your
Fellows Program promises to be in
bringing bright and promising young
leaders to Yale and equipping them to
help their own nations make the most of
globalization I had the privilege of
meeting them nan and I spent about 30 45
minutes with them and we walked away
quite excited about the program program
and the contribution I expect they will
make here and in their respective
countries it has often been said that
globalized globalization is what
distinguishes our era from all its
predecessors
globalization we are told is redefined
and not only the way we engage the world
but how we communicate with each other
globalization is commonly understood to
describe the increase in flow of goods
services capital technology information
ideas and labor at the global level
driven by liberalisation of policies and
technological change for a time this
logic was born by really borne out by
reality
indeed it worked so well that in many
cases underlying schisms were ignored in
the belief that the rising tide of
material growth will eliminate important
political difference
and social grievances however over the
past few years I and many others have
urged greater consideration for the
potential political backlash in the
social as well as economic consequences
of globalization if they are left
unattended today I would like to share
some thoughts with you on the Eco and an
equally important aspect of
globalization namely the potential to be
a truly integrated and inclusive force
and the very real dangers if it fails to
live up to that potential in other words
just as we worry about the gap between
the haves and the have-nots
we need to be equally concerned about
the gulf between insiders and outsiders
in a globalized world where no broader
where no border is impermeable and where
the privileges economic as well as
political and social of the few are
painfully apparent to those multitudes
who stole yen for liberty and
opportunity we need in short to direct
our energies towards realizing the
aspiration inherent in the awkward but
revealing Arabic translation of the word
globalization which means literally
world inclusivity world inclusivity of
course globalization is not wholly new
as far back as we can trace human
history people have traveled they have
traded they have been on the move
colonized and migrated and in the
process have transformed the places they
came from and the places which they
generated what makes our era different
is the degree of interpenetration
the speed with which change is taken
place and the dramatic and ever-growing
gaps this process is creating between
insiders and outsiders today I wish to
suggest that one way to address this new
division between those who are
benefiting from globalization and those
who are simple simply see it as one more
manifestation of the inequity of the
world is to pursue an inclusive
globalization whose purpose lies not
only in opening markets but in expanding
opportunity and promoting cooperation by
this I mean the need to ensure that
globalization of a committee of
economists and societies is supported
and sustained by a global community to
create a wider more expansive definition
of our duties to our fellow men and
women in a global village and to ensure
that globalization when it benefits them
all economically politically and
socially the question before us
therefore is not whether globalization
is good or bad but rather how we adapt
our policies priorities and personal
choices to account for the realities of
a new era in a world without walls we
can no longer think and not as if only
the local matters as if we owe
allegiance and solidarity only to those
within immediate vicinity to our own
city or to our own state such a world
demands that we tear down the walls in
our own minds as well those separating
us from them rich from poor white from
black Christian from Muslim from Geo so
that we are able to recognize the untold
ways in which we can all benefit
from cooperation and solidarity across
lines of nationality race or economic
development whether it is in the area of
crime health the environment or the
fight against terrorism interdependence
has cease to be an abstract concept and
become a reality in our lives
it has become a necessity this poses
real challenge not only to political
leaders but to civil society NGOs
businesses labor unions think as an
ordinary citizens of every nation we
need to think and rethink what belonging
means what community means in order to
be able to embrace this fate and embrace
the fate of distant people and realize
that globalization's glass house must be
open to all if it is to remain secure
this will require leaders in every
sector to present the choices facing the
public in a different light they need to
make the difficult but necessary case
that we cannot continue to exclude the
poor the disenfranchised or those who
are denied basic right or liberty and
self-determination or that if we do we
cannot at the same time hope to secure
lasting peace and prosperity of course
including all those people in our circle
of concern won't be easy we all feel a
deeply rooted sense of loyalty to those
closest to us families friends fellow
citizens of city and country to say that
we and here I think in particular of
those of us privileged to live in the
developed world should include citizens
of poor and distant countries in our
circle of concern and to suggest that we
have a nobly
to help them achieve their rights and
opportunities in a spirit of tolerance
and diversity is to ask a lot I
recognized that and yet does
globalization leave us any choice
either we help the outsiders in a
globalized world out of a sense of moral
obligation or enlightened self-interest
or we will find ourselves compelled to
do so tomorrow when their problems
become our problems in a world without
walls there are myriad ways in which
nations can act on this imperative by
opening markets for the products of
developing countries by increased
development assistance and here the
conference at Monterey on financing for
development was a good start and I'm
happy and I would want to thank
president idea once again for the very
crucial role he played as most of you
know he chaired a panel on financing for
development with other eminent persons
and they produce a wonderful report
which made an impact at the conference
so you've got a good man here by
promoting good and transparent
governance by addressing diseases and
environmental problems that have not
reached our shores or at least not yet
by recognizing obligations to provide
asylum by fostering a more orderly
process of integrating migrants and by
valuing pluralism as an overarching
priority in every state we need to think
globally and to consider not only
domestic factors but also international
ones as integral to decision making
today in governments businesses and
organizations this does not mean you
know uniformity of thought or just one
approach
there are quite naturally a great
variety of ways that we can think and
act globally and in so doing celebrate
and strengthen global diversity in this
sense the local is not in opposition to
the global but it's infused and enriched
with global impulses and influences
essential to realize in this new reality
it's a dialogue across nations and
cultures based on common values and
common concerns the United Nations
itself was created in the belief that
dialogue can triumph over discord the
diversity is a universal virtue and that
the peoples of the world are far more
united by their common fate than they
are divided by their separate identities
this dialogue must take place every day
among all nations not like that among
all nations within and between
civilizations cultures and groups but it
must be based on a genuinely shared
values without these values values
rooted in the charter of the United
Nations and the Universal Declaration of
Human Rights no peace can be lasting and
no prosperity secured that is the lesson
of the United Nations first half-century
it is a lesson we ignore at our peril
while it may seem somewhat vague to
speak of a globalization based on shared
values the vision of the world is seeks
to create is quite clear and quite
specific it is a well defined by
solidarity and understanding tolerance
of dissent celebration of cultural
diversity an insistence on fundamental
universal human rights and belief in the
right of people everywhere to have a say
in how they are governed it is a world
characterized by the belief that
diversity of human cultures is something
to be celebrated not feared this vision
is based on on on the understanding that
we are the products of many cultures and
impulses that our strengths lie in
combining the familiar were the foreign
that is not to say that we cannot
rightly take pride in our particular
faith or heritage we can and we should
but the notion that what is ours is
necessarily in conflict but what is
theirs is both false and dangerous it
has resulted in endless enmity and
conflict leading men and women to commit
the greatest of crimes in the name of
higher art and it need not be so people
of different religions and cultures live
side-by-side in almost every part of the
world and most of us have overlapping
identities which unites us with very
different groups we can love what we are
without hating what and who we are not
we can thrive in our own tradition even
as we learn from others and come to
respect their teachings you who are
privileged to perceive knowledge and
understanding in this great institution
know this truth in every day and every
hour of your work here my dear friends
if today after the horror of 11
September we see better and we see
further we will realize that humanity is
indivisible new threats make no
distinction between races
nations are regions a new insecurity has
entered every mind regardless of wealth
or status a deeper awareness of the
bonds of the bonds that bind us all in
pain as in prosperity has gripped
youngin over the process of
globalization cannot remain unchanged in
face of this recognition it must be able
to benefit those at the margins as well
as those at the centre the poor as well
as a privileged the shackled as well as
a free the global reaction to 11
September attacks should give us courage
and hope that we can succeed in this
fight the sight of people gathering in
every city in every part of the world
from every religion to mourn and to
express solidarity with the people of
the United States proved more eloquently
than any ways that terrorism is not an
issue that divides humanity but one that
unites it I do not thereby mean to
suggest that the aftermath of the
attacks or more broadly the effects of
globalization have been anyway
introduced a uniform way that will be
beneficial to the broader cause of
tolerance and coexistence indeed over
the past year we have witnessed a
dramatic rise in acts of anti-semitism
in Europe and elsewhere and we have seen
Muslims become the victims of suspicion
hostility and even physical attacks in
this country and elsewhere these acts of
bigotry and ignorance can be seen as the
ugly faces of an exclusive antagonistic
globalization an inclusive globalization
must address all these ills as well
the victims of the attacks of 11
September were first and foremost the
innocent civilians who lost their lives
and the families who now grieve for them
but peace tolerance mutual respect human
rights the rule of law and the global
economy are all among the casualties of
the terrorists acts repairing the damage
done to the fabric of the international
community restoring trust among peoples
and cultures will not be easy but just
as a concerted international response
can make the work of terrorists much
harder to accomplish so should the unity
born of this tragedy bring all nations
together in defense of the most basic
right the right of all peoples to live
in peace and security and all inclusive
globalization will be central to achieve
in this fundamental goal thank you very
much
okay
Thank You Ven
thank you and please
mr. secretary-general there are many
many questions and given the fact that
you have to go back to New York to
continue working on the problem that all
of us know we will be able only to
transmit a few of these questions to you
we have chosen a few of the most
difficult ones well the first one is
Saddam Hussein a threat to the
international community it's so how
would you suggest dealing with him
effectively I told you these are very
intelligent and keen students I see no
Iraq the dossier of Iraq which also
means Saddam Hussein has been on the UN
dossier for about 12 years now at the
end of the war resolutions were passed
requiring that Iraq be disarmed the
inspectors were sent in from 1991 and
they stayed till 98 between 91 and 96
they did quite a lot of disarmament
destroyed about nine 900 ballistic
missiles neutralized their nuclear
efforts destroy some of the chemical
weapons they had less success with like
biological weapons but they had by no
means finished their work when they had
to leave in December 1998
since then we've not had inspectors back
in Iraq the council demands that the
inspectors should not only the same Iraq
and insure that Iraq has been disarmed
but to certify to the council that the
job has been completed and then the
council would eventually decide to lift
sanctions provided the disarmament
function and other resolutions
been implemented until that
certification has come e and the council
has assured itself that there are no
weapons of mass destruction we will have
to assume that Iraq does possess weapons
of mass destruction on Monday and
Tuesday the chief inspector Blake's met
with the Iraqi delegation in Vienna and
they have agreed to cooperate but of
course there is history to this and
there are members who believe that the
inspectors cannot go back and continue
business as usual and the steps should
be taken to strengthen the disarmament
regime and the inspectors for them to be
able to do their work more effectively
the council is now discussing that
resolution the resolution has many
several components first that Iraq
should disarm and indicate some
timeframes for certain actions to take
place they will demand the Iraq or press
fully with the inspectors and give them
unimpeded and unfettered access and if
the inspectors were to come back to say
that they did not get the cooperation
and they could not do their work the
council will have to take a decision of
what to do which some believe should
include the use of force the question
that the council is also grappling with
should others be in one resolution or
should we have two resolutions the
United States will prefer one resolution
demanding that Iraq disarms cooperates
with inspectors within a certain
prescribed time limit and if it fails
face all possible consequences other
council members would want to have a
two-step approach demand Iraq to perform
demand that it cooperates with the
inspectors send them in and if they do
not get their cooperation to come back
to the council and then the council will
pass the second resolution on what
action should be taken against Iraq
and so this is where we are so in short
the council does not believe that Iraq
is clean of weapons of mass destruction
and that certification that decision
judgment will be based on reports and
certification from the inspectors the UN
inspectors thank you thank you mr.
secretary you know a few weeks before
President Bush speech to the United
Nations General Assembly there was this
sense that I'm particularly after his
West Point speech there was this
sentiment in the sense that the United
States would deal with the Iraqi
question without going through the
United Nations and even without going
through the US Congress what would have
happened mr. secretary-general to the
multilateral system and particularly
with the United Nations if the United
States had decided to go it alone in
dealing with the Iraqi question I think
it would have been a real challenge to
the multilateral system as I indicated
in my statement to the General Assembly
on the 12th of September that each
country has an inherent right under
article 55 of the 51 article 51 of the
UN Charter to defend itself when
attacked but when the country decides or
group of countries decide to do
something about broader threat to
international peace and security
I don't see any other option than to go
to the Security Council and the UN for
legitimate for legitimacy and for
endorsement and other authorization to
take that action and if we do not insist
on that minimum order I think we could
find ourselves in a very difficult world
where countries can decide to take
against a country's not because they
threatened or they've been attacked but
they see a broader threat to
international peace on security that
responsibility under the Charter belongs
to the Security Council Thank You mr.
secretary-general what do you think the
United Nations can do with regard to the
resolution of the Kashmir issue says in
India but also in Pakistan yeah well we
we have observers on the ground but not
that they are going to solve the problem
I think the UN and my myself I've always
made my good offices available and I
work with lots of governments to help
resolve conflicts but the parties must
be opening they must be prepared to
accept the good offices they must be
prepared to work with a mediator this is
not the case in this particular conflict
both not there the parties have not
jointly agreed to accept a mediator or
in bring in a third party and have
tended to work bilaterally with support
from friendly nations and recently by
United States and United Kingdom and I
myself have also been on the phone with
the leaders of both countries I think
what is important is that these efforts
continue and that we do not only
de-escalate the tensions which has this
today and get the two governments to
withdraw their troops from the border
because when you have almost a million
men confronting each other accidents can
happen so we need to work with them to
deescalate we need to not only get them
to de-escalate but continue the process
and seek a longer-term solution and I
hope that the recent efforts being made
by friendly governments will help move
the process forward it is not an issue
that is actively bitten before the
Security Council
because of what I have described as the
unwillingness of both parties to refer
to the council or even deal with the
third-party mediator and would want to
do it deal with it bilaterally and if
they can do that well and good we will
support them we will work with them and
give whatever encouragement we can thank
you would you comment on the United
States attitude towards the
International Criminal Court that's an
easy one to Preston Levine you have
tough students here no on the issue of
the court earlier this year we had that
big debate in the UN when US asked for a
blanket exemption for US troops and u.s.
citizens and that really did disturb
member states particularly those who
have their ratified the room status and
felt that it would undermine the court
even before it got off the ground and
we're determined not to do anything that
will go contrary to the statues of the
court u.s. has an indicator that is
going to try and work our bilateral
agreements with governments that will
give it will give you a citizen's
assumption several agreements I
understand have already been signed the
European Union to get her collectively
review this issue and they seem to
believe they've come up with a
compromise where they will not pursue
American citizens provided the put on
trial in u.s. course this in a way is
exactly what it room statue says the
statues makes it very clear that where
you have a good legal system and the
government is prepared to put the
accused on trial and to prosecute the
court has no role it is only in those
situations where a government is either
unable or unwilling to prosecute
the International Criminal Court can
step in and take action so if they are
able to work out arrangements that are
in conformity with the cause said were
the statues and I would not see much a
problem but if it goes beyond that and
the arrangements are seen as weakened in
the court then it creates quite a lot of
problems even though US has not ratified
the statues all they signed it and
indicated they are not going to ratify
some say they have unsigned it I don't
think you can unsign a documentary of
sign it's a historic fact but you may
decide not to ratify it and that says
some but I think if the court gets off
to a good start
our points how standard prosecutors our
standin judges and really begins to do a
good job and establishes his credibility
I think I will not be surprised if the
US tends to the court and the US may
even need the court much more than
others because US has far greater global
exposure than any country that I know
and there may be situations where they
may want to resort to the court to deal
with certain situation until the court
system was established we had to resort
to establishment of ad hoc tribunals we
have ad hoc tribunal for Bosnia we have
one for Rwanda and we are setting up a
special court for Sierra Leone and I had
been in negotiations with who in sand in
Cambodia to set up another court for
Khmer Rouge how many ad hoc tribunals
are we going to set up and in fact in
most of these cases the is also seen as
a justice of the victim I mean if you
talk to Malaysia which today he was
thinking if he had won he won't be in
court so you have these kinds of
situations and when we have a standard
International Criminal Court I think we
will get away from all these accusations
and all these tensions and I also
believe that we would we are fine
puttin in place the missing link in
international law international criminal
law because until these tribunals were
set up and until the Criminal Court was
set up it was much easier to put a man
on trial if he killed one or two people
but when they killed hundreds and were
responsible for ethnic cleansing inaud
he had no means of getting often they
were the presidents they were with the
generals and they got away with it
here we are over 20 years later thinking
of what we do about Khmer Rouge and how
do we set up a court to trial those who
kill their millions now we have a court
and I hope it sends a message to those
who would act with impunity that they
cannot escape they'll be brought to
account and there is a court that is
waiting to put them on trial and the
u.s. as the country a democratic country
a country that believes in rule of law I
hope in time will find this way to
support in the court not today not
tomorrow but I hope the position is not
immutable and that they will come on boy
the secretary-general what is the United
Nations doing to tackle
DHH IB epidemic I'm glad you raised that
point I think is the greatest tragedy
the world is facing today Africa is the
hardest hit and the AIDS epidemic is not
just a health issue it's a security
issue and it's an issue of economic
development in some countries is taken
of the most productive people men and
women in their prime in some countries
the skill and teachers faster than they
can be replaced and life expectancy in
some countries is dropping as much as
1020 years and this is a real
catastrophe I spoke to one of the past
weekend I went on a retreat with the
senior UN officials and the head of well
food program who is dealing with the
crisis of farming in Central in South
and Africa the 6,000 African countries
had been on a field trip and it came
said I've never seen anything like this
he took his wife and he said this change
our lives that he go to some villages
and you see a grandmother no other
parents her children are gone and their
husbands or spouses are gone and she was
responsible for 22 children and she has
to cope with them and in some cases even
where the people are sick there's no
medication hospitals are crowded and
what is difficult and the most painful
one is the mother to child transmission
in them and the awful thing is that most
of the victims today are women innocent
young were men and others who have been
taken advantage of and we tried the UN
tried to help by setting up the Global
Fund when we set up the Global Fund a
little over a year ago I indicated that
we need a seven to ten billion dollar
say
we've got 2 billion it's a good start
but it's not enough not half nearly
arsenal we have challenged
pharmaceutical companies to work with us
to reduce the prices and make sure that
we can get medication to the poor and
some have responded well as some
foundations like Gates Foundation the
Rockefeller Foundation and other
foundations are helping some governments
are doing more to help the poor
countries but I must be stress that ace
is a global epidemic Africa is a hard
asset but is spreading very fast in Asia
in the former Soviet republics in China
in the Soviet Union in the Caribbean and
the figures are frightening that if we
don't do anything about this four or
five countries in another 10 to 15 years
they will have about 50 million infected
so it is a really really serious problem
that we all need to become engaged in
and wherever I have been of challenge
the leaders to leave a fight to show
leadership and to mobilize the entire
societies to play a role and not to keep
silent and to remove the stigma and
discrimination attached to the disease
and I constantly remind them that
silence is dead and they have to lead
and speak up so whatever we can do
individually it's equally who will be
important and so it's a global problem
for all of us and I urge everyone in
their own little way whatever they can
do to help is the international
community meeting the Millennium
Development Goals that were adopted two
years ago mr. secretary-general the
results are mixed we are not doing as
well as we we should and if we are going
to meet the targets by 2015 we should
really step up
our efforts some areas have done worse
Southeast Asia has done well they have
come down from 28 28 percent to 14
percent cutted by half people living in
abject poverty South Asia has gone down
from men
44 percent to 37 percent Africa has a
worst record is moved from 48 to 47 only
1% decrease and if we are going to meet
the goals that we have set ourselves we
need to do much much more we need to
ensure that the assistance the
Development Assistance which has been
promised is given we strengthen the
institutions and that we also provide
access to markets for some of these
countries and in the area of education
ensure that we get more girls in school
there has been some progress by still
the gap has only been bridged by about
25 percent thank you and the last
question do you ever feel limited by
restrictions on your authority if so at
what times do I ever feel the feel you
ever feel limited by restrictions on
your authority and if so at what times
I'm not sure I can say that I I feel
defeated I find ways of fighting the
restrict limited now I find the way of
fighting the limitations on my authority
because in a way it's a bit like
behaving as a victim if you behave as a
victim you become a victim and I think
the way is when you've got you've been
given it a huge job to do a responsible
task normally you would expect the
authority and the resources to come with
it they don't always come with it but
you have to try and determine how you
can make a difference despite the
limitations that those who give you the
responsibility try to place on you or
despite the lack of resources that you
need to get it done you have to find
creative ways of doing it
I must there are moments of frustration
there are moments of incomprehension
that I don't understand that if we
really wanted to do this the will the
resources are there the technology is
there the money's there why can't we
must other well what does it take what
will shake us what will move us so we go
through those moments of frustration and
wonder what else you can do to get
results to shake people but you should
never be defeated by it because if you
feel defeated and they give up then all
is lost
particular if you are in charge if the
captain gives up you've lost the ship